reine d'angleterre
c'est pas un job rigolo défilent on
défile on trinque
tout se fait bel et bien sûr finit par
s'ennuyer à mourir
alors hier pour fêter son anniversaire
la reine a voulu s'éclater direction
paris en route pour ses rêves les plus
fous ici
elisabeth kazakh rostock rose monte
foods of wales exciting n'est-il pas
plus fou encore cette incroyable
rencontre à l'ambassade
un inconnu surgit de nulle part
elisabeth glisse de charme
mike dunn naissent quelle aventure ça
swingue pour le queen's burstein
il nous a déversé votre poster
anniversaire qui adam la reine quel pied
barbès elizabeth
c'est coloré superb n'est-il pas que
demander de plus
[Musique]
mais oui c'est vrai que les fleurs les
fleurs toujours assorties au tailleur il
y en a marre
et les jours c'est lisabeth watts
couronnement god save the bear gershwin
j'aimerais bien en faire fortune
assister davantage de bonheur dans la
vie privée de vos enfants
mais non on va pas vous sur signé avec
charles zentai et les autres c'est votre
anniversaire elizabeth
vous êtes toujours jeune et nous sommes
tous vos enfants
vous encanailler majesté admirable
n'est-il pas marvelous de fouiner a faim
de découvrir la superb mode bicentenaire
de s'envoyer un p'tit kawa c'est réussi
the queen s'éclate et rêve de bray de
violence dans les stades britanniques
ce serait pas mal ce serait pas mal
alors notre cadeau majesté ce stade vide
rien que pour vous car pour nous vous
avez toujours 20 ans alors on dit
[Musique]
graz afc deux monuments fierté du monde
moderne
alors faut vous raconter d'histoires
c'est parfois qu'on allait des tournages
comme s'il se passe des choses bizarres
et la madame funfrock de l'agent richard
kim c'est son nom elle s'appelle
huguette funfrock celle du feu ce qui
veut dire en gros rigolo pantalon voilà
c'est passé c'est la course reine
d'angleterre elle est passée de la
géniale et elle se promenait dans la
gare gare saint lazare à la gare du nord
la gare du nord et racontez nous ce qui
s'est passé il s'est passé quelque chose
que vous allez voir maintenant c'est à
dire qu'une une femme une femme a cru
qu'il s'agissait de la vraie reine
d'angleterre et lui a amené son enfant
est touché voilà et la cellule et parler
en anglais à regarder vraiment ces
rencontres entre une dame était comme
vous et la renommée terre
[Musique]
m
à paris
je peux dire que je n'ai jamais eu de
quolibets ou de réflexions désagréables
au contraire toutes les réflexions que
j'ai pu avoir des gens y viennent vers
moi et c'est un peu dommage qu'ils
rendent à l'arel à travers moi donc ça
l'aura du personnage est brisée sur moi
mais pas envie d'être vraiment la reine
m'a vraiment pas je ne l'en but je
n'envie jeunes absolument pas ce genre
de rôle et jeu plaît beaucoup sa majesté
d'avoir à tenir un rôle aussi délicat
aussi dur mais dans votre vie privée par
exemple est-ce que ça a joué sur votre
comportement ou non leur absolument pas
dans la vie privée je tiens absolument
n'y pense même pas c'est lorsque j'ai
posé la couronne également tôt le
chapeau c'est c'est terminé je n'y pense
plus jamais essayé d'imiter je dirais
même que récemment lorsqu'il ya eu le
film du jubilé de la reine
je les regardais faire j'ai misé c'est
quand même extraordinaire elle marche
comme moi elle me faisait mal comme moi
j'étais même sérieuse n hésitez pas moi
qui suis et talc et mon physique
il est différent sur lesquels c'est que
elle vous permet de gagner votre vie
vous l'a gagné bien alors là je crois
que je ne peux pas dire d'avoir gagné ma
vie sur le dos de la reine si j'ose dire
non parce que si je mettais évidemment
boutabout tout ce que j'ai pu gagner
depuis plus gagné en disant je crois que
j'aurais à peu près la moitié du smic
[Musique]